[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen viel
Fußball gibt es heute von Sven Foss
schönen guten Abend zuerst aber der
Blick auf die Reise des Kanzlers in den
Nahen
Osten ein solidaritätsbesuch in schwerer
Zeit Bundeskanzler Scholz trifft Israels
Regierungschef und Angehörige deutscher
Trauer und offene Fragen nach dem
Anschlag von Brüssel ein mutmaßlicher
Islamist hatte gestern zwei schwedische
Fußballfans
ermordet und Bücher Geschäfte Kultur und
viel Politik die Frankfurter Buchmesse
beginnt mit einem pldoier für Freiheit
und
Demokratie beim Besuch des Kanzlers
heute in Israel geht's um viel es geht
Olaf Scholz um die Solidarität mit
Israel aber auch um die freilass der
Geiseln der Hamas und um die
Verhinderung eines Flächenbrandes in der
Region morgen will auch US-Präsident
Biden in das Land reisen bevor wir auf
die militärische und humanitäre Lager in
Gaza schauen blicken wir erst einmal auf
die diplomatischen Bemühungen den
Konflikt einzudämmen l
wepot der Bundeskanzler in schwieriger
Mission es geht darum Israel im Kampf
gegen die Hamas zu unterstützen und
zugleich die Auswirkungen des Konflikts
auf die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza zu
begrenzen der Terror der hamasso der
Kanzler nach dem Gespräch mit
Regierungschef Netanyahu lasse das Blut
in den Adern gefrieren es ist völlig
klar israel hat das völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Recht sich gegen diesen
Terror zu wehren ein Staat jeder Staat
hat die Pflicht seine Bürger und Bürger
zu schützen Regierungschef Netanyahu
ließ keinen Zweifel an Israels
Entschlossenheit genau wie die Welt
zusammengerückt ist um die Nazis zu
besiegen später den islamischen Staat so
müssen wir jetzt alle gemeinsam die
Hamas
besiegen vor der deutschen Botschaft in
Tel Aviv versammelten sich unterdessen
verzweifelte Familien einiger von der
hamasentführter Geiseln deren Schicksal
völlig unklar ist sie hoffen auf die
Hilfe des
Kanzlers unter den Verschleppten sind
auch deutsche Ihnen wie all den anderen
Geiseln gilt unser Augenmerk wir bemühen
uns nach Kräften ihre Freilassung zu
erreichen das versenere Diplomaten wie
US-Außenminister Blinken der heute
Palästinenser Präsident Abbas traf
morgen wird US-Präsident Biden in Israel
erwartet es geht auch um dringende Hilfe
für die notleidende Bevölkerung in Gaza
mit dem Ministerpräsidenten habe ich
eben über Wege gesprochen den Menschen
in Gaza schnellst möglich humanitäre
Hilfe zukommen zu lassen dan bislang
aber hat Israel der Einrichtung eines
humanitären Korridors nicht
zugestimmt und die Reise des Kanzlers
begleitet für uns Theo Koll Theo gerade
trifft sich der Kanzler mit Angehörigen
deutscher Geiseln was kann Deutschland
für die Freilassung
tun also der Kanzler traf sich muss man
sagen mit den Angehörigen denn wir sind
jetzt alle gerade in die Bunker in der
Deutschen Botschaft gerannt weil es
wieder raketenalarm gab das Gespräch
dürfte also auch für den Kanzler
unterbrochen worden sein aber insgesamt
hat er sich verhalten optimistisch
gezeigt er sagte die Telefone glühen
aber er will sich nicht öffentlich
äußern wichtig dabei sind vor allem
Staaten wie Qatar und der Kanzler hat
sich ja mit dem emia von Qatar schon
getroffen das ist ein Land das sowohl
die Spitze der Hamas beherbergt im Land
als auch gezeigt hat
in Afghanistan als die Taliban
übernommen haben war das Land so gut
vernetzt dass es vielen Menschen aus dem
Land helfen konnte also das sind die
Querverbindungen die der Kanzler
versucht zu nutzen insgesamt ist er hier
um volle Solidarität dem Freund Israel
zu zeigen und gleichzeitig auch einen
Flächenbrand verhindern helfen die
Eskalation die entstehen könnte durch
die Bodenoffensive ist allen bewusst und
der
versucht zu mäßigen er hat hier an Recht
und Gesetz erinnert und bittet Israel
das immer im Blick zu haben dass es hier
nicht zu einer weiteren Eskalation
kommen muss danke schön Theo
K
blicken wir nach Gaza wohin auch die
Geiseln verschleppt wurden mindestens
3000 Menschen sollen in den
Küstenstreifen seit Beginn des Krieges
getötet und rund 12500 Menschen verletzt
worden sein so die gesundheitsbördehörde
in Gaza jetzt hat die Hammers erstmals
ein Video von einer Geisel gezeigt Peter
Bömer
berichtet eine junge Geisel deren
verletzte Arm offenbar in einem
Krankenhaus im Gazastreifen behandelt
wird die Terrororganisation Hamas
veröffentlichte gest dieses Video das
ZDF zeigt daraus nur Standbilder die
junge Frau sagt ich bin 21 Jahre alt und
komme aus schoham holt mich hier bitte
so schnell wie möglich raus die Mutter
der jungen Frau am Vormittag vor der
Presse ich bitte die Welt darum mir mein
Baby
[Musik]
zurückzubringen man sieht dass sie unter
Schock steht dass sie Schmerzen
hat ich sehe dass sie Dinge sagt die ihr
vorgesagt werden
aber ich sehe auch dass sie stabil ist
unklar wann und wo das Video aufgenommen
wurde die israelische Armee teilte heute
mit in diesem Video versucht die her
Mass sich als humane Organisation
darzustellen aber sie ist eine brutale
und mörderische Organisation die
verantwortlich ist für den Tod von
Kindern Frauen und älteren Menschen
Raffa der Grenzübergang zwischen Ägypten
und dem Gazastreifen bleibt gesperrt
endlos Schlangen von voller Hilfsmittel
aber nichts kommt hinin nichts
hinaus israelische Armee setzte die
Bombenangriffe auf Ziele im
gaserstreifen Fort hier ziehen sie Tote
und Verletzte aus den Trümmern das Leid
der Menschen die hier
wohnen wir saßen hier und haben gebacken
wir haben nichts gemacht die Leute sind
hungrig weil wir nicht mal Strom haben
oder Wasser ich schwöre wir haben nur
gebacken und plötzlich dieser Luftschlag
über uns und dann war plötzlich alles
dunkel überleben zwischen Bomben und
Elend im gazaastreifen für
hunderttausende Menschen tägliche
Realität humanitäre Hilfe und sichere
Gebiete für die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
Michael bwerunge das sollen ja
eigentlich Vorbedingung gewesen sein für
den Besuch des US-Präsidenten morgen in
Israel so hat es aus Washington geheißen
aber wir haben es gesehen bisher ist
noch nichts von einem solchen möglichen
Abkommen von einer solchen humanitären
Hilfe auch nur annäherend umgesetzt
dementsprechend groß sind die
Erwartungen an den Besuch des
US-Präsidenten Morgen und der hat einige
Ziele auf seiner Agenda er will Israel
klare Unterstützung für das Recht und
sogar die Pflicht zur Selbstverteidigung
geben und auch das Israel weitere
Attacken abwehren kann er will
Fortschritte in der geiselfrage machen
er will anmahnen dass es bei der
weiteren Kriegsführung humanitäre Hilfe
und auch möglicherweise
andere Maßnahmen geben soll um die
Zivilbevölkerung zu schüzen das klingt
ein bisschen wie die Quadratur des
Kreises und das ist es auch wohl zumal
die strategischen Kriegsziele weiter
unklar bleiben denn die langerwartete
Bodenoffensive die scheint erstmal auf
halten gesetzt zu sein danke für diese
Einschätzung Michael
bwerunge krisendiplomatie Ringen um
humanitäre Hilfe und die Entwicklung der
Kämpfe über alles halten wir Sie online
ständig auf dem Laufenden mit dem
Liveblog auf ZDF heute und in unserer
App wir schauen die Ukraine die Ukraine
hat nach den Worten von Präsident
selenski erstmals
Langstreckenraketen vom Typ attchems
eingesetzt die von den USA gelieferten
Waffen hätten sich als sehr präzise
erwiesen gleichzeitig meldet die Ukraine
sie hätte den russischen
Luftstreitkräften einen schweren Schlag
zugefügt und zwar ganz im Süden bei
bertjansk hinter der Frontlinie ob dabei
die neuen Langstreckenraketen eingesetzt
wurden ist
unklar seit 10 Jahren treibt China sein
umstrittenes Infrastrukturprojekt neue
Seidenstraße voran aus diesem Anlass hat
die Regierung heute und morgen zu einem
internationalen Forum geladen auch
russlands Präsident Putin reiste nach
Peking und traf sich am Rande mit
Ungarns Regierungschef Orban Putin
sprach von einer Genugtuung dass es noch
Länder in Europa gebe die den Kontakt
mit Russland hielten morgen ist ein
Gespräch Putins mit China Präsident hi
geplant wir schauen nach Brüssel der
mutmaßliche Attentäter der gestern zwei
schwedische Fußballfans erschossen und
eine weitere Person verletzt haben soll
ist tot er war von der belgischen
Polizei angeschossen worden das
Europäische Parlament hat heute eine
Schweigeminute für die Opfer abgehalten
wir dürfen den Hass nicht siegen lassen
sagte Parlamentspräsidentin metzola was
bisher über die Tat bekannt ist
berichtet gun Krüger
Brüssel skarbeg in diesem Viertel nimmt
die Polizei am Morgen einen Mann fest
und muss schießen versuche ihn wieder zu
beleben Scheitern im Krankenwagen liegt
wohl ein Terrorist der mitten unter
ihnen
lebte es ist das erste Mal dass jemand
den ich kenne so ein Verbrechen
begeht ich finde keine
Worte der Schütze schraubt seine Waffe
zusammen
Z erst auf ein
[Musik]
Taxi und tötet dann zwei Fußballfans die
aus Schweden für ein Länderspiel nach
Brüssel angereist
waren nie zuvor in der Neuzeit waren
Schweden und schwedische Interessen so
stark bedroht wie
jetzt der mutmaßliche Täter war Tunesier
im Video nach der Tat sympathisiert er
mit dem islamischen Staat und betont die
Herkunft seiner
Opfer wir müssen das noch genau
untersuchen aber es scheint er hat
gezielt Schweden ausgewählt wegen der
Koranverbrennungen
dort sein Asylantrag abgelehnt sein
Aufenthalt illegal der Fall exemplarisch
für Belgiens
premier mein erster Schluss daraus ist
wenn jemand ausreisepflichtig ist dann
müssen wir das
durchsetzenans Länder blieben übrigens
bis Mitternacht im Stadion zur
Sicherheit und nach Belgiens
fußballmotto alle
zusammen bundesinnenministerin Feser
will stärker gegen Schleuser und
irreguläre Migration vorgehen und lässt
nun doch stationäre Grenzkontrollen zu
neu sind die an den Grenzen zu Polen
Tschechien und der Schweiz an der Grenze
zu Österreich werden sie verlängert denn
in diesem Jahr hat die Bundespolizei
bislang über 98 000 unerlaubte einreisen
festgestellt das sind jetzt schon mehr
als im gesamten Vorjahr die meisten
illegalen Übertritte gibt es an den
Grenzen zu Polen und Tschechien Stefan
Kelch berichtet alle müssen runter von
der Autobahn A17 die bei Schleusern
beliebte Route über die
deutsch-tschechische Grenze hat nun ein
nadelö eine stationäre
Grenzkontrolle die stationären nehmen
eine gewisse Dynamik raus das muss man
jetzt so sehen ne wir können uns jetzt
jetzt alle Fahrzeuge vor Ort hier
anschauen die Kontrollstelle ist quasi
eine Filterfunktion noch weitere neun
Tage wird hier kontrolliert
möglicherweise auch länger
stichprobenartig vor allem bei
Kleintransportern und Bussen gestern
wurden sieben Syrer ohne Papiere
entdeckt heute sieben Türken das
Verständnis für solche stationären
Kontrollen ist durchaus da ja ja ja F
tja das ist nun mal notwendig in dieser
Zeit für Kontrolle habe ich absolut
Verständis dafür finde ich gut
ich Staus ja eher weniger ne aber für
Kontrolle es muss sein mögliche Staus
und Behinderungen in den Grenzregionen
waren bislang Hauptargument gegen
stationäre Kontrollen wir wissen
selbstverständlich um die Grenzpendler
und Grenzgänger gerade in den
Grenzregionen haben wir viele
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer aus
dem tschechischen aber auch an der
polnischen Grenze die sich irgendwo in
der Wirtschaft bei uns in der
Bundesrepublik einbringen und denen
wollen wir natürlich den täglichen
Arbeitsweg und den Rückweg äh wenn es es
geht nicht erschweren auch auf der
Görlitzer Altstadtbrücke wird jetzt
kontrolliert aus Polen kommen derzeit
die meisten illegalen Grenzgänger am
Übergang Ludwigsdorf wurde heute ein
provisorisches Kontrollzentrum
aufgebaut gestiegene Energiepreise zu
viel Bürokratie schleppende
Digitalisierung das beklagen viele
Unternehmen in Deutschland und haben
deshalb beim arbeitgebertag in Berlin
die Bundesregierung zum Handeln
aufgefordert Verbandspräsident sagte die
Stimmung und der Wirtschaft sei gekippt
die Lage in den Betrieben Ernst
Bundeskanzler Scholz bat um Vertrauen er
sei zuversichtlich dass schon bald
Vorschriften geändert würden um
Planungen und Genehmigungen zu
beschleunigen sagte er vor seiner
Abreise nach
Israel Sorgen macht der Wirtschaft auch
die konjunkturelle Lage um
0,4% könnte die Wirtschaftsleistung in
diesem Jahr zurückgehen erwartet die
Bundesregierung die EU-Staaten wollen
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher besser
vor stark schwankenden Strompreisen
schützen darauf haben sich die
Energieminister nach langen Verhandlung
geeinigt jetzt beginnen Verhandlung mit
dem Parlament der Strompreis soll danach
weniger als bisher vom aktuellen
Gaspreis abhängen die Mitgliedstaaten
können mit den Stromerzeugern künftig
langfristige Verträge abschließen starke
Preisschwankungen würden vom stat
ausgeglichen die Einigung verbessere den
Zugang von Verbrauchern und Industrie zu
günstigen Strompreisen sagte
Wirtschaftsminister
habbeck teure Fitnessgeräte in Mannheim
die kaum eine Sportlerin nutzt oder
millionenkosten beim PKW mautdebarkel
100 Fälle von Steuerverschwendung hat
der Bund der Steuerzahler aufgelistet in
seinem diesjährigen Schwarzbuch weitere
Beispiele eine energiesparkampagne der
Bundesregierung mit Binsenweisheiten wie
Heizung runterdrehen oder weniger warm
wasserverbrauchen Kosten 83 Millionen
Euro und ein Parkhaus in Wuppertal
saniert für 4 Millionen doch Autos
durften zwei Jahre lang nicht rein weil
die Stadt kein Betreiber
fand blicken wir auf die Frankfurter
Buchmesse sie steht für freien
Meinungsaustausch für Empathie darauf
weisen die veranstaltler gerade dieses
Jahr besonders hin die Welt ist aus den
Fugen geraten sagte heute der direkt der
Buchmesse Jürgen Boos natürlich auch mit
Blick auf die Gewalteskalation in Israel
Isabelle de laweger hat sich am
Eröffnungstag einen Eindruck von dieser
75 Buchmesse gemacht ehrengastland ist
diesmal
Slowenien die slowenische Präsidentin
Natascha pirzmusa wird von der deutschen
kulturstaatsministerin begleitet Claudia
rot ist für den Bundeskanzler
eingesprungen er ist nach Israel gereist
in einer zunehmend unsicheren Welt seien
Bücher umso wichtiger
gerade
jetzt brauchen wir die Freiheit des
Denkens die Vielfalt der Bücher und
Perspektiven und genau dafür steht die
Frankfurter Buchmesse Waben der Worte
unter diesem Motto präsentierte
Ehrengast Slowenien seine Literatur
darunter jede Menge Lyrik und Bücher
über die abwechslungsreiche Natur des
Landes prägend für die Autoren sei vor
allem die Lage Sloweniens mitten in
Europa Grenzen Sloweniens haben sich in
der Geschichte oft verschoben das Land
gehörte so zu ganz unterschiedlichen
Nationen und all diese Einflüsse die
deutschen mediterranen und slawischen
gehören zu unserem Alltag und zur Kunst
und
Literatur wie aber geht es dem buchmkt
wirtschaftlich die gestiegenen Kosten
für den rohstoffpapier und für den Druck
sind geblieben das mache viele Verlage
vorsichtiger wenn Unternehmen
angespannte wirtschaftliche Lage haben
dann riskieren sie weniger und
Neuentdeckung ist ein hundertprozentiges
Risiko und das ist schade also da müssen
wir gegen anwiken denn die Neuentdeckung
von heute sind die Stars von morgen was
aber auch in diesem Jahr boomt Kinder
und Jugendliteratur sowie
Hörbücher und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport
also wer die deutsche
fußballntionalmannschaft Spiel sehen
will der muss sich ja wirklich ein
weckerstellen sen ne ja und zwar auf 2
Uhr nachts denn dann trifft das deutsche
Team zum Abschluss seiner US-Reise auf
Mexiko nach dem Sieg gegen die USA ist
es das zweite Spiel unter Bundestrainer
Julian nagelsmann und das in einer der
sportmetropolen Amerikas Philadelphia
die Stadt mit den berühmten 72 Stufen
auf denen syvester stellone als Boxer
Rocky ballb trainierte nicht weit von
der Statue entfernt liegt die WM-Arena
für 2026 in der 50.000 mexikanische Fans
erwartet werden das Team des neuen
Nationaltrainers Heime lano 12 der
Weltrangliste ein komplett anderer
Gegner als die usbys sind keine
Mannschaft die so extrem viel zocken
will wie die USA weil insgesamt eine
Mannschaft die leidenschaftlich spielt
nlich wie die Zuschauer auch erwartet
werden von mir dass es schon noch mal
ein Tick emotionaler wird aber auch eine
andere Art von Fußball nach dem
gelungenen USA Kick wird es keine große
Rotation geben zu erwarten ist dass
Thomas Müller und Niklas sühle in die
stadrücken gute Einsatzchancen hat auch
Stürmer Kevin Berenz der mit 32 Jahren
vor seinem debü
steht für die EM in Deutschland planen
kann seit gestern auch die
österreichische Nationalmannschaft das
Team von Trainer Ralf Rangnick gewann in
Aserbaidschan mit 1:0 und qualifizierte
sich damit vorzeitig für die EURO
zittern bis zum Schluss mussten gestern
die Niederlande erst in der
Nachspielzeit erzielte Virgil van Dijk
per velfmeter das 1:0 gegen Griechenland
damit stehen die Niederländer nun auf
Platz 2 in der Gruppe hinter Frankreich
und vor Griechenland und brauchen noch
einen Sieg um sich zu
qualifizieren Fußball buundesligist
Mainz 05 hat seinen Profi anwa elgasi
vom Spiel und Trainingsbetrieb
freigestellt der 28-Jährige hatte mit
einem inzwischen gelöschten Post zum
Konflikt Konflikt im Nahen Osten für
Wirbel gesorgt indem er Israel indirekt
das Existenzrecht absprach me05
distanziert sich deutlich von den
Inhalten des Posts diese Position sei
für den Verein nicht tolerierbar
und das war's vom Sport danke schön s
das Wetter wird unbeständiger mehr
gleich von östtin terli das heute
journal läuft um 21:45 Uhr mit Marietta
Slomka auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter der hohe
Luftdruck schwindet und das erkennen wir
vor allem da dran dass ein neues Tief
aufzieht und das bringt aus
südwestlichen Richtungen hier Regen mit
in der kommenden Nacht ist es erst
einmal trocken hauptsächlich in der
Osthälfte bildet sich Nebel nach Westen
hin ist es teilweise aufgeklärt oder
etwas bewölkt dazu Temperaturen von 0
bis -3° frostig kalt hauptsächlich in
den Nebelgebieten ansonsten im Norden
deutlich milder bei 9° Richtung Nordsee
oder 7° am oberrehein Morgen starten wir
mit Nebel in den östlichen Landesteilen
in den Tag ganz im Westen gibt
Sonnenschein aber die Bewölkung nimmt
hier schon mal zu und spätestens zum
Nachmittag gibt's im Südwesten Regen
ganz im Osten merken sie nichts davon da
scheint häufig die Sonne oder auch hier
im Südosten Deutschlands bei höchsten
Temperaturen meist so zwischen 12 und
15° teils 16° im Rhein meineebiet oder
am niederrehein oder 18° an den Alpen
die nächsten Tage sehr wechselhaftes
Wetter teils windig im Norden kühler als
im Süden 9 bis 21° am Donnerstag einen
schönen Abend